welcome back to tasty's making a big the
show where we make
giant versions of some of america's most
beloved foods we're in a different time
different place different circumstances
but tasty's love for giant food hasn't
changed
so today we are gonna be making a giant
cheesecake
why i like cheesecake enough talking
let's get started
so the first thing that we're gonna do
is the crust i have
120 graham crackers and then i'm going
to
process it and go
[Music]
i like graham crackers a lot all right
let's go crush them
all right one back down ten thousand
more to go
all right i think we're done it's like
sand
thank you for your hard work today
you've been a great service back to the
equipment room with you
now it's time to melt seven sticks of
butter
it barely fits in the pot
[Music]
i've been babies hitting this butter
quite a while now i don't even want to
think about how many calories are in
here
let me know in the comments
some sugar probably a lot of sugar and
some salt
oh my god it smells so good jeez
this looks like a beach when the wave
just
went away and your sand castle got
destroyed because you weren't paying
attention
and then your mom says it's time to go
home
you don't want to go home i don't know
where i was going with that
i found a little oven safe kind of
box there's a real name for this i don't
know what it's called so i'm going to
call it a white box
got a really big tray this is the
biggest tray that we have in the entire
tasty kitchen
as you can see we have lasagna noodles
molasses
i am going to try and create a foil wall
reminiscent of the foil wall i made in a
100 layer lasagna video i made a while
back
i dropped out of engineering school so
let's see if i can still do this
it's actually true okay
hold on oh boy
and this goes down one
two three four
five six six by four
that's thick the molasses is basically
an edible glue
one two three four five six
a little break four okay hope this works
fold over the edges
and where are you
good catch alvin to make sure that the
cheesecake doesn't stick
i'm going to line this with parchment
paper
call me bob ross like that
that's half i'm gonna make another half
oh boy please don't break
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
one second oh there we go
okay looks like that 75
of an engineering degree is starting to
show
because this structure is 75 complete
and 75 stable okay
we're just gonna do that and then i'm
gonna use this to smooth it out
asmr
[Music]
this is like a zen garden but you can
eat it
this is taking a little longer than i
expected
this crust is done nice and compact time
to go
bake this big boy
please fit it's gonna bake for
until it's ready so until then
i think it's time to make the batter
okay we have a lot of stuff on the table
so the first thing that we're gonna do
is dump in a lot of cream cheese
everything on the table
may seem like a lot of stuff the thing
is
this is only a quarter of the batter
ingredients this bowl is the biggest
bowl we have and this is the maximum
amount of batter that we can make
at any given time oh yeah there we go
i want to be here for a while
okay and it's like a cream cheese
landscape up next
sour cream and heavy cream back at it
don't spill cream everywhere alvin that
would be bad
[Music]
getting a little bit of a workout doing
all this straight down the sides flowers
next don't go everywhere
okay last
the eggs a little bit
of vanilla and lemon zest it's time to
go further
beyond maximum speed
i can smell burning coming from the
machine
i'm pretty sure it wasn't supposed to be
left on this long
all right i think this is pretty much
done
batter is nice and smooth i have to do
three more of these
oh my god the crust is done
oh wow it smells so good oh
some of the molasses even dripped down
and caramelized that's really pretty
let's bring this back carefully
oh boy let's get you down here
it has been a very long time in the back
kitchen i had some culinary help
we have 20 liters of cheesecake batter
i just want to read to you guys the
recipe there are 10 cups of sugar
50 tablespoons of butter 320 ounces of
cream cheese which is
40 philadelphia blocks 5 cups of heavy
cream 10 cups of sour cream and 3 cups
of flour
pinch of kosher salt 10 teaspoons of
vanilla extract
40 eggs and the zest of four lemons
now as my dad used to say that's a lot
of stuff
oh that was satisfying
[Music]
i'm having so much fun that's like one
whole cheesecake just went in right
there
i think this recipe is like 10 or 15
times an
actual cheesecake all right you know
what let's dump it
now that's nice get in there
all right
nothing happened that was definitely not
one of the walls breaking
oh my god lift with your legs not your
back
yeah don't break don't break
don't break i can hear the wall
straining under the weight
oh sh it's spilling
all right it's spilling a little bit in
the back so i'm going to evacuate it
as fast as i can i'm gonna call for some
backup
okay so i put this guy on a cart
being very careful not to do
anything bad to it the tricky part is
going to be how to get this guy
into the oven hip may request some
assistance
absolutely okay if it is one of the
people
that makes this show happen all right on
three we're gonna lift
one two three okay
wow how amazing holy moly that was hard
thanks hip no problem okay so this guy's
gonna bake for probably like four hours
goodbye dude so to make the glaze for
the strawberry topping
let's start with some corn starch this
is some nice cranberry
and strawberry juice it helps thicken
the glaze
and the rest of the juice goes in here
and with some
sugar okay the juice is boiling gonna
slowly add this cornstarch thing and
then you gotta stir
constantly oh that got thick mega quick
i'ma turn you off
wow transform into like a gel in like
three seconds
look at that and then to give it some
extra shine
a little bit of corn syrup i know it's
not the best thing in the world but hey
it makes things shiny so we have a
little bit more strawberries
and a lot more glaze so we started with
thanks to
some help and work with the culinary
team in the back i don't know how many
pints it is it was like
a lot oh
that one's for me please stay
no stop dropping food on the floor you
dummy i don't think we're going to need
all of it
i do want to glaze these nicely
slowly gently
hello this is the big cheesecake as you
can see he's been chilling
resting let's see what we got
that's a big boy i can't even move it
let's trim this guy
this is a very soft and tender
cheesecake that is one nice cross
section
stay
cover up all the cracks
holy [ __ ] that looks dope on the wide
angle
that's so wild all right i think this is
it
this is the giant cheesecake with the
strawberry topping it is probably 50 to
60 pounds at this point but i'm very
happy
i have a friend her name is hannah she
really likes cheesecake
i think it'll be fun to facetime her and
see what she thinks of this
hi alvin how are you good yeah we're on
set
you are someone who has made a lot of
cheesecake videos
on tasty i remember every time we'd have
meetings with the team
we refer to hannah as like the
cheesecake queen there's not a single
day
that goes by that i don't want to eat
cheesecake so
today we made actually you know what
i'm just going to show you so excited oh
my gosh one
two three
alvin holy moly
alvin it's gorgeous well i'm glad you
like it how many packages of cream
cheese i have to know
you know those philadelphia ones right
the eight ounce ones we use 40 of them
every time i think you're like done
surprising me
you come up with something else this is
incredible she's pink queen approved
that's what we wanted
wow it's bending the knife all right
look at that yeah this cheesecake
probably feeds a family of four
in the finish some piping all right
one slice of the cheesecake
time to eat that's nice
[Music]
whoa it almost tastes better than the
regular cheesecakes i made
soft fluffy crust is nice very happy
with this result so you guys are
probably wondering at this point
what is going to happen with all of this
cheesecake
i really wanted to share this and give
this to my friends and people that i
admire
just like i normally would but in
current circumstances that really isn't
possible
so if you excuse me i have a lot of
cheesecake to consume
that's really good
[Music]
you